Alright, so over the course of this lesson we've
discussed how to perform some basic computations using the
Mapreduce programming model. For example, counting words in a
collection of text, or aggregating adhar generated in a particular
district. These jobs are easy to write in the
Mapreduce programming model, and even so, solving these problems with
Mapreduce requires a lot more code than they would
if we didn't use Mapreduce. For example, compare our original
word count solution using Python dictionaries to
our Mapreduce solution. As you can see,
the Mapreduce implementation is quite a deal
more involved. You can imagine that if
we wanted to do something more complicated,
say compute the similarity between the number
of documents, or implement some machine learning
algorithm, things could get pretty hairy, pretty fast.